This, you're a very popular, what
I would call conservative thinker.
Yeah. But you're very young.
Like how did this all happen?
How did you become this Fox News
personality? Conservative thinker?
Yeah. I mean I just like launched a
youtube channel and ah, fucking youtube.
Yeah. Youtube where, where magic
happens. You choose a strange place.
It's a strange, strange place. Yeah.
Well it's the internet and the Internet
stream things happen on the Internet.
But yeah, I just kind of, I
was really passionate. Um,
I understood I had studied for like,
it sounds strange,
but like I spent a year underground
like studying politics once I had my red
pill moment, if that's what
you want to call. Explain that.
Because you used to be a liberal, right?
And then you became a conservative.
That's correct.
So what was it?
So the story like really starts
with like high school I guess.
Like you know how things can happen to
you in life and they don't make sense
when they happen. You're like, why God me?
And then when you get a little older and
you're like, this makes perfect sense.
Right?
So I was the quote unquote victim of a
hate crime when I was in high school.
When you say quote unquote victims,
no, I hate the word victim and it's,
I'm like Anne again early.
I can see why early on I've sort of
developed this mentality that like being a
vague,
there's no value in being a victim and
people rush to call people a victim.
They rush to call
somebody to get aggressor.
So how do you describe it that
you experienced at his experience?
Something that was labeled a hate crime?
I W I wouldn't even call it a hate crime.
I think we live in a
label obsessed culture.
And before we seek to understand what
happened, we seek to like put it in a box.
Yeah. Like so what? Someone has to be
a demon and someone has to be an right.
Right,
right.
So what happened was I received some
voice mail messages from about four kids
and the like, you know, the language
was, it was pretty strong. It was like,
we're going to tar and
feather your family. Um,
we're going to put a ball in the back of
your head that we did the Martin Luther
King, like you know Edward Edward, Edward.
Um, you received these on your phone?
On my cell phone? Yeah. How'd
they get your phone number? Well,
there was a prank phone call,
so I didn't know I was like four male
voices and I was like in high school at
the time and I was like,
okay.
I cannot think of for human beings
that want me dead, that would say like,
we're going up,
put a ball in the back of your head like
we did to Martin Luther King and Rosa
Parks. Like naming your own school.
Where were you? What part of the country?
Stanford High School in Connecticut.
Okay. That's a shit hole. Yeah,
it's a total shit hole.
Hey Connecticut. Yeah.
No I didn't because I
think it's on a shit hole.
It's a running joke. I'm sorry. Oh Shit.
I gotta grab my Buddy Tommy Junior.
He lives in Connecticut and
I'm always telling him, dude,
you gotta move out of Connecticut.
And it became this terrible running joke
where I talk about the Connecticut's to
worst. Have you actually
been a bunch of times? Yeah,
I used to work there all
the time. What's it? Well,
I used to work in all over Connecticut.
When I was doing standup,
I would drive from
Boston into Connecticut.
I did like a lot of gigs in Hartford.
I did gigs.
Hartford is a shit hole.
It's a shithole bridge is a shithole.
Shout out to Mario and starling
junior though. Yeah. Um,
he was a boxer that came out of a
Hartford. Yeah. Big Time boxer. Marlin,
Marlin, starling. Um,
but when you were in high school,
right,
somebody
started doing this prank call
and shit on you and was this,
it was all in one, like four
voices is tied to like a boyfriend
boyfriends house. When I got the
calls and I just put to silence,
it was like blocked number. So I was
like, I didn't think anything of it.
And then like when I listened to it, like
it was like some pretty horrific stuff.
Like I definitely cried, you
know, I was 17 years old. Um,
and then the next day at school I took
this like philosophy class and like,
I don't know what the topic was.
I don't know what prompted me to raise
my hand and introduced what had happened
last night as like, you know, a segway.
Maybe I just needed to get off my chest.
But like the teacher like
spazzed out and was like, get up,
we're going to the principal's office.
Like, you know, you have to report this.
He brings me into the office.
The principal like freaked out.
Like she just like the language was like,
you know, if it was shocking, you know.
Um,
and then she called like the resource
officer and then like the next period of
my life was like a blackout because it
turned out that three of the kids I had
never even met.
Like they,
this was like maybe some kids
that had their first beer.
One of the kids I was like friends with,
but we were arguing because he was upset
that I was like spending so much time
with my boyfriend, but
he's gay. Like he was,
it wasn't like he just was
like Jelly, like, you know,
like just like I using Alpha everyday
started hanging off my boyfriend was a
stupid thing. Wasn't a
hundred percent. Yeah, no,
he's a 100% gay from what I'm told.
But um,
yeah, so, uh, petty. Yeah.
And then it was like,
here are my three friends and they were
all going to get drunk and call these,
call this black girl. And you know, it's
easy to say awful things until like this.
Like you're don't have
to look at a human being.
Like it's easy to say awful things.
But unfortunately for me,
one of the people in the car happened to
be the current governor of Connecticut
Sun.
So this turned from like some kids prank
called to like said some awful things
to like front page of the newspaper
throughout the entire shift. Connecticut,
a little bit in New York,
Naacp outside of my school I have to,
it was like this situation that
was talk about outrage culture.
My first like introduction to outrage
culture and the things that sort of formed
my thoughts. Like this was a very
formative experience in my life. Um,
which to me it was, it was nonpolitical,
but it was like my life wasn't mine.
Like I went from like
sitting down watching,
I was watching Talladega nights with my
boyfriend to being the most discussed
person in the state of Connecticut.
And what was interesting about it was
just that because it was the governor of
Connecticut sign that was in this car,
they had to get the FBI involved to
determine the authenticity of the like,
like maybe she called herself right, they
heal instead of just saying like, yes,
it was my son.
He actually let the FBI investigate for
six weeks and waited for a son to get
arrested six weeks late.
You know what I mean? Like
was just want to see if he can get
away with it. Cause this is politics,
you know what I mean? Like,
can we get away within,
is it plausible for us to
get away with it? You know,
so six weeks of the entire
state, I didn't, I left school.
People were like fighting on my behalf,
fighting our school home school. Yeah.
Yeah. It was, it was just like,
yeah, yeah. This was just like,
it was like a monstrosity of a situation
and it was one of those things where
like literally like letters to the editor
and be like, mom's like, talk about,
you know, outrage culture. Right. I don't
believe Candice, yeah, this happened,
this girl,
I believe she called herself like,
I'm just looking for attention one night
and I just decided to say I was going
to hang by family from a tree.
Isn't it funny that someone would
even have an opinion on that? It's,
it's bizarre. Like I believe her
writes letters to the editor. Like I,
the whole thing is weird retrospectively,
right? Like I don't believe her,
but that is what like life is about,
right?
Like you have to write
a youtube right now.
I still know this is how you're
gonna fucking, yeah, exactly.
So it was the situation that like,
it was just completely out of my control.
And then as quick as it,
how did these kids got arrested?
And then as quick as it happened,
it was over, um, for like everyone,
but not for me. Are
these kids, right, right.
Like so I never wanted these kids
to get arrested. Like if no one,
like this whole situation
was taken out of my hands.
People thought I didn't go to the police
and like my teacher went to the police.
It turned into this do these kids
were labeled publicly racists. Right?
The youngest kid in the car,
it was 14 I'm not comfortable with ever
labeling a 14 year old racist. Right.
Or any of these kids racist.
These are kids and in my opinion,
adults that failed to act like adults.
Adults that failed to take a step
back and say, okay, why would,
what would prompt these kids do this?
Why is it so easy to be mean? Right.
Why is it so easy nowadays for
children to be mean and no one to me,
like when I really thought about that,
I went through like five years of like
anorexia because of the situation.
Because of that one and I was
the victim. Yeah. And Yeah,
you went through Anorexia.
Yeah.
Which is so weird now because
like people that know me now,
like there's no way you never didn't eat.
But I did.
I did like did not eat
for like five years.
I had issues with Anorexia because
I mean I actually has a disease that
genuinely is about control.
It's about asserting control of your life.
And I felt that I had my,
like my life was fine and then
like people took the narrative, um,
and I can decide to determine what
the narrative was. You're in your,
you're a victim or maybe you're a liar,
you know, you're, these kids are racist,
these kids are this.
And just nobody really thought that.
Like you actually wrote all of our lives,
right.
Like for a little bit like these kids
went on to have like Duis and get arrested
and got into drugs and it was because
of this outbreak of everything that
happened. Yeah. And I was like, would have
been totally cool with an apology. Like,
you know what I mean? Like, sorry.
Well good for you for
looking at it that way.
And as that's hard to do because everybody
loves when they are allowed to get
outraged.
Everybody loves get outraged.
Obviously what they did to you was
horrible. But I think a lot of kids,
especially if they're drinking,
they don't even understand
how stupid and gross it is,
what they do and they just know they can
do it and they get a thrill out of it.
And then there's that mob mentality when
there's like a bunch of people together
doing the same thing. Exactly.
Amp it up and start saying crazy.
We understand the,
when you just like think about it as a
human being and not as somebody who has
to opinion, like you're like, hey, we're
going to call this black girl, right?
You've got a bunch of kids were going
to just say mean things to her on the
phone and you don't have to
look her in the face. Right?
It's like if I hold up this pen
and I'm like, just say mean stuff.
Like someone's going to get, you could
say anything to this pen. So it's,
it's sort of, um, it, it was a
formative experience that um,
in retrospect I understand has so
much to do with why I am who I am.
Cause I hated that.
Like that label obsessed culture and
the outrage machine and then like,
oh okay we're done. But like, you know,
forget the people that whose
lives we just like, no.
Do you know those people anymore?
I don't,
I I know like the siblings of them because
I was friends. Like that's the thing,
like one of the people that was involved,
I was very good friends with
his brother and it's like,
you're just going to tell
me this kid's like a racist.
Like I actually knew the kid's
mother, you know, like nobody cared.
It was just a hot story.
Really Racist. Just stupid.
I mean stupid did something
stupid and they do that.
That was a way that they could scare you,
right.
That they could and they
might've been drunk like drunk.
Maybe it was their first beer.
Right.
But people can do well,
the youngest was 14 the youngest and
this person was labeled a racist.
Like that's to me is like, that's harsh.
People say, Oh, you're too forgiving.
Labeled him a racist, they said
was most certainly racist. Yes.
The words are racist. Right. Can
Somebody, I guess the question is,
can somebody say something,
say a word that is racist and
not be a racist human being? Yes.
I think now I'm going to tell
you why. Yes. Okay. Okay.